bonjour Cécile Duflot bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être notre invité ce matin on
est ravi de vous recevoir vous êtes
directrice générale d'Oxfam France et on
va parler ensemble de beaucoup de sujets
qu'on s'occupe Oxfam et notamment les
questions du pouvoir d'achat puisque
c'est fait partie évidemment de vos
préoccupations hier avait lieu une
manifestation elle appelle de plusieurs
syndicats plusieurs dizaines de milliers
de personnes étaient dans les rues de
France est-ce que vous êtes favorable à
une hausse généralisée des salaires
est-ce que pour vous c'est ça la bonne
réponse en tout cas c'est assez logique
que ce soit le cas oui dans une
situation
double à la fois d'inflation et puis
dans une situation aussi où il y a une
augmentation de ce qu'on appelle les
dépenses contraintes c'est-à-dire ce que
vous devez payer quoi qu'il arrive votre
loyer votre énergie et on voit bien que
la question du prix de l'énergie une
question absolument fondamentale donc il
faut lier l'augmentation des salaires et
puis aussi la nécessaire sobriété les
deux vont parler de la sobriété mais il
y a une ça marche aussi contre la vie
chère et contre l'inaction climatique
justement qui est en préparation à
l'appel de la France insoumise vous y
participerez vous à titre personnel je
sais pas et comme citoyenne je sais pas
encore Oxfam nous on travaille au sein
d'un collectif de deux collectifs le
collectif alliance écologique et social
avec la CGT Greenpeace et puis le pack
du poivre de vivre et on est très
attentif à ce qu'il y ait cette
cette action collective et elle est
effectivement aussi une action très
auprès des syndicats qui ont décidé
d'autres
sources de mobilisation ça veut pas dire
qu'on regarde pas avec intérêt tous les
lieux d'expression de la réalité du fait
qu'on peut mener une politique
différente de celle qui est menée
aujourd'hui est-ce que vous préconisez
vous chez Oxfam pour augmenter le
pouvoir d'achat des Français qu'elle
doit être la bonne réponse pour vous
alors nous on est vous le savez on est
une organisation qui lit très fortement
la question climatique et la question la
justice sociale et pour ça on a
travaillé notamment sur la publication
d'un manifeste fiscal qui montre que
avec 15 mesures fiscales d'évolution la
fiscalité existante on arrive à financer
11 grands plans d'investissements avec
65 milliards d'euros de recettes
supplémentaires par an et donc c'est
vraiment ça c'est de faire le choix
d'investir dans les secteurs qui en ont
besoin un certain nombre de services
publics la santé est évidemment mais
aussi la transition énergétique et puis
de se dire que pour ça il faut davantage
de justice sociale et notamment une
fiscalité plus progressive une fiscalité
plus écologique et évidemment dans le
débat actuel une fiscalité sur les
profits tombés du ciel certains les
appellent est super profit mais nous on
pense que c'est l'expression anglaise
winfo profit et c'est une réalité c'est
à dire des entreprises qui n'ont rien
fait de particulier si ce n'est qu'elles
ont bénéficié la situation et aussi
qu'elles ont bénéficié du fait que
pendant des mois l'état donc nous tous
avons été extrêmement soutenant de
l'économie et des entreprises parce que
vous vous souvenez l'idée du je cite
d'une taxe sur les bénéfices
exceptionnels des grandes entreprises
dans tous les secteurs exactement
d'abord c'est quoi un bénéfice
exceptionnel un bénéfice exceptionnel
c'est très facile c'est quand vous avez
pendant
des années fait 8 9 millions milliards
suivants en l'occurrence on est plus sur
des milliards de bénéfices et que vous
passez à 16 milliards comme total sans
avoir rien fait de spécifique mais ça
veut dire qu'il y a effectivement cette
base taxable qui est différente donc
taxer les bénéfices exceptionnels c'est
considéré qu'il y a un une pente normale
et puis la frange qui s'explique par les
circonstances qui s'expliquent par une
situation de de de goulot d'étranglement
c'est le cas notamment pour certains
entreprises des transports et bien cette
part là elle est plus taxée mais c'est
pas quelque chose de très
révolutionnaire ça existait dans
beaucoup de pays Margaret Thatcher
l'avait même elle fait et en 2020 c'est
ce qui s'est passé avec les mutuelles et
les assurances on a dit vous avez
bénéficié du chômage partiel et en même
temps vous avez très peu payé parce
qu'il y a plus quasiment de cambriolages
ni accident de la route du coup il y a
eu cette surtaxe donc c'est quelque
chose finalement d'assez banal et pour
tout dire maintenant c'est défendu par
le FMI la Banque mondiale et même le
chef économiste de la BCE il y a
quelques jours c'est à dire c'est pas
uniquement les plusieurs énergétique non
parce qu'il y a des secteurs et
notamment certains secteurs de l'agro
industrie qui ont bénéficié aussi de la
situation et certains secteurs
alimentaires et avec en plus des marges
qui s'accroissent au détriment des
consommateurs vous avez entendu Emmanuel
Macron lui plaît pour un mécanisme de
contribution européenne sur les
opérateurs énergétiques réalisant des
super profits ça devait financer les
mesures prises par les États en faveur
du pouvoir d'achat ça c'est une bonne
mesure pour vous ça va pas assez loin
alors on peut le faire tout de suite en
France et surtout ce que nous nous
demandons c'est qui est un budget
rectificatif sur les profits de 2022
qu'on n'attendent pas 2023 parce qu'en
2022 il y a déjà ces bénéfices
exceptionnels considérables je dis ils
sont considérables et les recettes qu'on
a estimées de cet axe serait de 10 à 20
milliards d'euros donc on voit bien que
c'est très important pour l'instant ce
qu'il y a dans le PLF mais j'ai entendu
Bruno Le Maire c'était un peu agacé à
raison c'est la suppression de la CVAE
c'est-à-dire cette axe qui est
majoritairement payé par des très
grandes entreprises notamment du secteur
financier et du secteur énergétique donc
là non seulement on ne taxe pas leur
super profit mais en plus on va leur
faire un réseau fiscal on marche sur la
tête quand on voit tout ce qu'on a
besoin de financer et pour finir on peut
financer effectivement une aide au
ménage et notamment face à la crise
énergétique qui connaissent mais aussi
au petit et moyen d'entreprise et nous
on plaide à Oxfam pour que cette taxe
elle soit sur tous les secteurs elle
soit sur donc ces profits exceptionnels
et qui s'expliquent pas par une
réalisation exceptionnelle des
entreprises et qu'elle bénéficie au
ménage et aux petites et moyennes
entreprises qui vivent difficilement la
situation énergétique vous parlez des
profits total tout à l'heure de ces
profits records mais total dit que ça va
lui permettre d'investir un milliard de
dollars supplémentaires dans les
énergies renouvelables est-ce que ils
ont fait combien de ils ont fait combien
de profits exceptionnels ce que ça a pas
du bon aussi ils ont fait combien de
profils exceptionnels beaucoup plus 16
et ils investissent enfin vraiment ça
c'est pour le coup c'est de la com et
c'est toujours ce que vous dites pas
c'est toujours un milliard d'investis
dans l'espace
2022 on voit et je parle après ce qui
vient de se passer en Floride et comme
la déclaré Biden sans doute le plus
dévastateur l'ouragan le plus
dévastateur dans l'histoire de la
Floride pourquoi parce qu'on sait très
bien que la crise climatique c'est des
événements extrêmes les
mégafeux qu'on a vécu en Gironde c'est
des supers inondations enfin c'est ça
donc on doit laisser les fossiles dans
le sol c'est-à-dire que Total qui est
une entreprise qui exploite du pétrole
dois-je changer d'activité pas investir
un peu plus pour les énergies
renouvelables arrêtez au maximum de
contribuer à émettre du gaz à effet de
serre par l'extraction du pétrole c'est
simple et dans l'histoire du monde des
entreprises qui ont changé d'activité il
y en a tout plein donc c'est pas
suffisant de faire un petit truc en plus
et dans votre question quand vous dites
oui mais vous devriez être contente on
fait un petit bout c'est pas à l'échelle
du problème le sujet maintenant c'est et
tout le monde l'a compris c'est de
prendre ce grand virage de la sobriété
dans tous les secteurs pas seulement
dans le secteur énergétique dans le
secteur agricole aussi et dans celui des
bâtiments si on veut être à la hauteur
du problème tout simplement alors vous
le dites vous vouliez beaucoup les
questions de pouvoir d'achat et les
questions de sobriété il y a eu cette
expression qu'on a beaucoup entendu fin
du monde ou fin du mois est-ce que dans
cette période difficile pour les
Français et pour leur porte-monnaie vous
n'avez pas l'impression qu'ils ont fait
leur choix et que leur choix c'est
plutôt la fin du mois de fait ils vont
faire des économies d'énergie pour
essayer de dépenser moins d'argent pas
pas forcément par conviction écologique
mais pardon mais c'est ce que disent les
écologistes c'est ce que disent les ONG
comme aux femmes comme toutes les zones
du Réseau Action Climat depuis des
années faisons un plan d'efficacité
énergétique ça fera faire des économies
à tout le monde ce sera bon pour la
planète et bon pour le pouvoir d'achat
c'est ça qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
si on a un plan de rénovation thermique
à la hauteur de l'enjeu nous on est
vraiment très attaché à ça ça va créer
quoi ça va créer de l'emploi durable non
délocalisables ça va faire des économies
à tous les ménages qui du coup n'auront
plus à payer des factures énormes mais
au ménage en précarité énergétique qui
aujourd'hui se chauffe pas sont dans une
situation de grande difficulté et bien
ça leur permettra d'avoir juste la
capacité de vivre normalement donc ce
qui est étonnant c'est qu'on n'aille pas
aussi vite et aussi loin on voit bien
qu'on en a besoin et vous savez le débat
sur stream 2 je me souviens à quel point
on sait on a expliqué que c'était pas
une bonne solution ben on voit bien
qu'il s'est réglé de manière extrêmement
brutale donc la souveraineté énergétique
c'est à dire de produire notre propre
énergie dans des pensées beaucoup moins
c'est à la fois utile sur un plan
financier sur un plan écologique mais
aussi sur un plan géopolitique on le
voit on l'a sous notre nez on a
souveraineté énergétique de la France
elle passe aussi par le nucléaire pour
vous alors déjà il faut quand même se
dire que le nucléaire et on le voit bien
on continue à acheter de l'uranium à la
Russie on ne produit pas le combustible
sur notre sol donc c'est ça fait partie
des nombreuses
on va dire les gens qui ont couru autour
du nucléaire ce que tout le monde sait
sans débat j'allais dire ni caricatural
ni et motif c'est que ça n'est pas une
solution ça n'est pas une solution
d'abord parce que là on voit qu'on a
beaucoup de centrales qui sont à l'arrêt
ensuite parce que personne ne dit que ça
peut être une solution durable
d'investissement dans le nucléaire parce
qu'il y a eu des politiques publiques
qui voulaient baisser la part de
nucléaire sauf que là du coup la
question c'est de se dire est-ce que ça
coûte pas trop trop cher allez faisons
imaginons même que je puisse être
favorable est-ce que finalement
est-ce que c'était il suffit de lire la
pauvre de la mentheimer un rapport qui
date maintenant qui a été publié même
sous l'égide de l'Aloe député François
Brotte qui montre que ça n'est pas
concurrentiel y compris sur un plan
financier aujourd'hui développer les
énergies renouvelables c'est beaucoup
plus rentable financièrement donc c'est
suffisamment de production électrique
mais il y a un scénario il y a un
scénario qui a été publié par l'ADEME
sobriété plus renouvelable il y a des
scénarios qui tiennent et puis on va
encore faire des progrès entre les
éoliennes d'aujourd'hui et les éoliennes
il y a 15 ans c'est pas du tout la même
efficacité donc c'est là qu'il faut
investir et peut-être qu'il y a encore
d'autres capacités à capter notamment
l'énergie solaire vous savez chaque jour
la Terre reçoit des milliers et des
milliers de fois de plus d'énergie de la
part du soleil que ce dont on a besoin
pour l'ensemble des activités humaines
donc on pourrait imaginer que la
recherche soit consacrée à essayer de
trouver un meilleur moyen de capter
cette source cette source d'énergie je
dis pas vraiment pas continuer de
chercher mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que les vieilles solutions du 20e
siècle elles sont c'est pas les bonnes
enfin ça ne marche plus c'est plus à
l'échelle du problème le gouvernement a
présenté un projet d'accélération de
développement des énergies renouvelables
lundi dernier en conseil des ministres
il va dans le bon sens pour vous ce
texte alors oui mais il faut aller
encore plus loin encore plus vite et
puis il faut aussi dire la vérité alors
c'est pas c'est pas moi qui le dis c'est
le secrétaire général à la transition
écologique qui a expliqué combien de
milliards d'euros aujourd'hui les
renouvelables rapportent à la France
c'est une énergie moins cher à produire
beaucoup plus durable beaucoup plus sûr
et beaucoup plus efficace finalement on
a vu ces images cette semaine
d'Elizabeth borne en doudoune de Bruno
Le Maire en col roulé comment vous avez
réagi ça vous a fait sourire vous dites
c'est un coup de com ou finalement c'est
bien de montrer le bon exemple alors si
un coup de com mais c'est un coup de com
bien vu pourquoi et donc moi je me moque
pas parce qu'en fait on dit il faut
chauffer à 18 19 degrés alors moi il se
trouve que je le fais depuis des années
et il y a une chose qui est vrai c'est
quand vous voulez travailler dans un
bureau à 19 degrés bah vous mettez un
pull vous n'êtes pas en T-shirt voilà et
donc c'est très simple de savoir si vous
êtes trop chauffer si vous supportez pas
votre pull parce que vous avez trop
chaud c'est que vous chauffez trop chez
vous donc c'est pas idiot ce qu'a dit
Bruno Le Maire c'est et de voilà et puis
ça surtout ça montre bah qu'on peut être
sérieuse et première ministre sans sans
avoir une veste et un petit chemisier
qui tient pas chaud donc franchement
c'est et par ailleurs l'association
nagawat l'a montré c'est le plus gros
gisement à l'échelle européenne
d'économie d'énergie de faire baisser la
température à l'intérieur des bâtiments
on va parler d'un autre sujet Cécile
Duflot un sujet qui vous tient à cœur ce
sont les violences sexuelles et sexy
c'est plusieurs affaires qui ont secoué
différents partis ces derniers jours
notamment la France insoumise et Europe
Écologie Les Verts Adrien cadenas et
Julien Bayou ont dû quitter leur
fonction Eric Dupond-Moretti le garde
des sceaux il dénonce une justice de
droit privé à l'oeuvre certains se font
dévorer par un monstre ils ont contribué
à créer comment vous avez réagi en
entendant cette phrase est-ce que vous
partagez ce point de vue franchement je
trouve qu'il est il est très brutal Eric
Dupond-Moretti alors ça peut aller quand
on est un grand avocat quand on est
ministre de la justice quand on sait la
situation la réalité de ce que sont les
violences faites aux et de l'impasse de
la solution judiciaire dans nombre de
cas en fait on a une obligation d'un peu
plus de modestie et de modération ça
veut pas dire que la question du droit
la question du droit de la défense la
question se pose pas ça c'est vrai mais
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on peut se dire
que depuis que la justice existe depuis
que on peut porter plainte pour viol ça
n'a pas fait régresser les cas de viol
ça n'a pas fait régresser
significativement les quatre féminicides
donc il y a bien une autre question qui
est posée alors quelle est la bonne
réponse
là c'est pas
des parties c'est la bonne réponse pour
vous alors moi je suis gênée avec le
terme enquête parce que enquête c'est un
métier quand vous êtes quand c'est des
gens que vous connaissez tout ça c'est
très compliqué donc je peux pas vous
répondre directement sur le procès la
procédure qui est mise en oeuvre dans le
cadre des parties que je connais pas par
cœur je peux vous dire ce que nous on
fait chez Oxfam parce qu'on a été
confronté à ça et ce qu'il faut dire
c'est qu'il y a aucun endroit de la
société ni une entreprise ni un média
qui peut être sûr que ça n'arrivera
jamais aussi une cellule nous on a un
dispositif qui permet de pouvoir faire
appel aussi à des gens de l'extérieur de
la structure qui peuvent le cas échéant
faire ce travail d'écouter les uns et
les autres pour essayer de documenter la
situation mais ce qui est sûr c'est
qu'il faut chercher en revanche il faut
il faut se dire que quand on ferme les
yeux quand on dit non non ça n'arrive
pas chez nous ou bah elles ont qu'à
porter plainte ces deux réponses là
elles sont totalement insuffisantes mais
vous vous faites appel à des gens de
l'extérieur est-ce que c'est pas aussi
ça le problème de ces cellules au sein
des parties c'est que c'est fait
uniquement en interne
ça peut éventualisation avoir des gens
qui sont formés en interne nous on a des
gens dans un certain nombre de cas où
c'est assez évident on a des gens qui
sont formés en interne il y a des
procédures avec plusieurs plusieurs
étapes mais oui ça peut être utile dans
un certain nombre de cas de pouvoir
faire appel à des personnes de
l'extérieur mais surtout des personnes
formées notamment quand on commence à
descendre dans la question de la nature
des relations on a évoqué cette question
des violences psychologiques on rentre
dans ce que
signifie une relation de couple et c'est
toujours très compliqué tant qu'on n'est
pas à l'intérieur de pouvoir documenter
la manière dont les choses se déroulent
donc oui il faut aussi de la prudence et
il faut il faut du calme et il faut du
respect et ça se fait pas au vu et au
sud de tout le monde ça c'est sûr parce
que sur les plateaux télés que Sandrine
Rousseau a eu tort de déballer ça sur un
plateau j'ai compris qu'elle s'était
sentie je l'ai écouté j'ai compris
qu'elle s'était sentie sous la pression
que sinon on allait lui dire vous dites
pas ce que vous savez mais
peut-être aussi parce que je suis plus
vieille je sais que quand on touche ces
matières qui relèvent de l'intime on
peut parler d'un certain nombre de cas
généraux de principe de méthode dès
qu'on parle de cas particulier
on met on expose les choses de manière
qui peuvent être aussi assez
irrémédiable pour les uns comme pour les
autres donc moi je suis attentive à ce
qu'il y ait de la de la prudence et du
respect des individus et peut-être aussi
parce que parce que j'étais une personne
exposée et que je sais ce que ça fait
quand quand des choses que vous vivez de
façon fracassantes dans un cadre intime
se retrouve sur trouve exposé
publiquement ça multiplie par 100 000
les dégâts voilà et puis dans ces
histoires il y a des personnes il y a
des familles il y a des enfants j'ai une
sensibilité personnelle à l'égard de ce
genre d'histoire qui fait que je sais
qu'il faut être prudent y compris pour
protéger les victimes vous avez eu aussi
à gérer ça vous avez à gérer
personnellement mais est-ce que vous
avez aussi à gérer ça quand vous étiez à
la tête d'Europe Écologie Les Verts
est-ce que vous avez été conf à des cas
comme ça où vous êtes demandé quoi faire
mais bien sûr mais il y a tout un tas de
cas on se demande quoi faire j'étais
confronté il y a très très longtemps à
une situation de violence conjugale
entre deux
adhérents mais avec une femme qui avait
expressivement demandé à ce que rien ne
soit fait que personne ne soit alerté ce
qui est souvent le cas les femmes
victimes de violences conjugales elles
sont souvent et c'est pas du tout il y a
pas une un mot de critique dans ce que
je vais dire au contraire ambivalente
elles essayent que ça serait pas elles
ont pas envie que ce soit enfin c'est
très compliqué parce que ça touche quand
vous êtes quand vous êtes violenté par
quelqu'un que par ailleurs vous aimez
vous êtes dans une sorte de de
complexité psychologique et souvent les
gens qui regardent ça de l'extérieur ont
une approche assez brutale en disant bah
elle a qu'à partir elle a qu'à parler
enfin c'est toujours plus compliqué donc
c'est pour ça que je dis il faut des
gens aussi qui soient des gens formés et
qui sachent comment agir face à ce genre
de situation mais là il y a aussi
l'intime et le politique qui se mêlent
notamment dans le cas de Julien Bayeux
Julien Bayeux il est accusé de violences
psychologiques il n'y a pas de
l'accusation de violence physique lui il
dit c'est une rupture qui s'est mal
passée je ne sais pas précisément de
quoi je suis accusée je n'ai pas pu être
entendu par la cellule d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts malgré mes nombreuses demandes
est-ce qu'il n'y a pas eu un problème
est-ce que ça ne va pas trop loin le
fait qu'il soit obligé de démissionner
de ses fonctions c'est très compliqué de
parler de d'un cas particulier je
comprends la position de certaines
féministes qui disent écoutez pendant
tellement longtemps on a tellement rien
fait que s'il y a des cas d'injustice
bah ça fait partie de ce mouvement
d'émancipation c'est un dommage
collataniste j'entends ça j'allais dire
que dans les moments de révolution ça
arrive il se trouve que mon passé à moi
c'est un engagement auprès de gens qui
étaient des personnes détenues c'est là
qui est né une partie de mon engagement
donc je sais aussi que les principes de
droit que les principes de
contradictoires sont des principes
essentiels donc il y a une tension entre
ces deux débats comme on l'a vu dans
dans d'autres situations et ça veut dire
qu'il y a pas de réponse évidente mais
je pense que c'est pour ça que je
parlais de évidence et de méthodes parce
que la seule réponse qu'on puisse avoir
face à ce genre de situation c'est de
c'est de pas faire de cas particulier
c'est à dire d'essayer de d'appliquer la
même règle à tout le monde et puis de le
faire même si ça vous satisfait pas en
tant que journaliste de façon un peu
préservée pour tout le monde et
j'insiste y compris pour les personnes
qui sont victimes mais c'est vrai que on
peut comprendre ce sentiment on dit mais
je sais même pas de quoi il s'agit alors
on va dire si il le sait mais là enfin
c'est très compliqué quand vous n'êtes
pas quand vous n'avez pas vécu ce genre
de situation
de d'avoir une analyse qui soit une
analyse extrêmement précise mais je le
dis j'ai aussi c'est sans doute le les
années qui font ça je dis que il faut
faire très attention aux dégâts dans le
temps de mettre sur la place publique
des histoires qui sont des histoires
douloureuses quelle qu'elle soit parce
qu'elles sont normalement et toujours du
registre de l'intime ça veut dire que
vous avez peur qu'aujourd'hui on soit
dans un engrenage qui aille trop loin
dans une tension complexe parce que oui
bien sûr on ne doit pas pouvoir dire
tous les hommes sont par essence des
agresseurs tous les hommes sont pas
essence des des gens violents pas du
tout ça n'est pas vrai et il peut aussi
y avoir des injustices et les femmes ne
sont pas toujours non plus parfaites ne
disent pas toujours la vérité peuvent
aussi être violentes ça existe c'est et
la vie et comme ça c'est pas blanc et
noir c'est gris clair et gris foncé mais
de façon globale c'est plus les femmes
qui sont victimes très largement et plus
les hommes qui sont désagresseurs ça
c'est une réalité qui est documentée et
qui n'est pas d'ailleurs que française
il y a un sujet sur lequel s'est
penchaîne Sénat cette semaine c'est la
question du porno et des violences
justement pornographiques le rapport
dénonce la façon dont le porno banalise
finalement c'est violent est-ce que pour
vous il faut aller jusqu'à interdire le
porno ben écoutez il se trouve que j'ai
écouté Laurence Rossignol qui était chez
vous et que j'ai découvert des choses
c'est à dire que effectivement je fais
pas partie des gens qui sont très au
fait et elle l'a dit assez bien elle l'a
dit en fait parfois en fait on n'imagine
pas la réalité de ce qui peut y avoir
derrière et l'accélération de la
violence qui a pu être le fait de la
multiplicité des plateformes je suis
très je suis je suis très interrogative
sur l'interdiction complète parce que
parce que
parce que la question de la liberté
d'expression parce que il peut y avoir
des femmes et des hommes qui considèrent
que vivent leur sexualité d'une manière
très différente y compris publique y
compris ça peut être leur liberté et il
y a des gens qui pour qui c'est vraiment
une décision une volonté un souhait une
liberté donc l'interdire de façon
définitive en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'aujourd'hui la situation est
absolument intolérable elle est
intolérable pour les enfants et les
jeunes qui se retrouvent confrontés à ça
moi j'ai découvert avec mes propres
enfants que même en regardant des
plateformes de streaming pour regarder
des séries pour enfants vous vous
retrouviez avec des pop-up qui affichent
des images que moi j'ai jamais vu de ma
vie avant d'avoir quasiment 18 19 ans
parce que l'une des questions du rapport
c'est évidemment des mineurs à ces
images la difficulté du contrôle
parental vous qui êtes maire de famille
vous vous le vivez de près ça c'est
difficile aujourd'hui d'interdire à ses
enfants quand ils ont un smartphone un
smartphone quand
les protéger parce que en fait quand
vous avez tout d'un coup qui surgit sur
votre écran une image avec une femme qui
a les jambes écartées et vous n'êtes pas
enfin ça peut être extrêmement choquant
et ça peut arriver dans un cas de c'est
ça qu'il faut comprendre où on peut se
dire ça c'est pas ils ont pas cherché ça
leur est tombé et ça peut ne pas
fonctionner donc oui c'est sûr qu'en
tout cas et la législation aujourd'hui
pour protéger les femmes qui notamment
celles qui veulent faire retirer toutes
ces vidéos qui doivent payer enfin on
aboutit à des situations qui sont d'un
niveau de sordide extrême donc je crois
que vraiment il faut agir ça c'est sûr
et je j'ai pas lu l'intégralité du
rapport mais je suis sûr que j'en
partage une grande partie des
conclusions parce que vraiment la
situation là elle est absolument
inacceptable et intolérable un autre
sujet on revient un peu sur ces
questions important sont évidemment ces
questions de pauvreté mais plutôt au
niveau international vous avez sans
doute écouté Emmanuel Macron à la
tribune de l'ONU c'était il y a une
dizaine de jours Emmanuel Macron il a
appelé les pays riches à en faire plus
pour aider les pays pauvres les pays du
sud-est-ce que vous avez été sensible à
cet appel du président de la République
très sensible pour une raison qui est
que effectivement on a réussi dans le
cas des objectifs de développement
durable à faire diminuer de façon très
importante l'extrême pauvreté dans le
monde on se heurte quand même un niveau
de pauvreté important et un niveau
d'inégalité important je fais pas partie
des gens qui sont toujours très
enthousiastes de la politique qui est
menée par le gouvernement mais aux
femmes à salué de manière réitérer les
efforts qui ont été faits en matière
d'augmentation de la publicité au
développement et ceux qui sont annoncés
dans ce prochain projet de loi de
finances c'est très bien maintenant il
faut améliorer la qualité de de ses
moyens la qualité ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'il soit davantage destiné au
pays les plus pauvres et aux populations
qui en ont le plus besoin dans ces pays
donc la manière dont est distribué cette
aide est importante il faut continuer
cet effort on est à 55 on n'est pas à
0,7 donc on a encore un pas accomplir et
puis aussi il faut donner une dimension
féministe à ce financement parce qu'on
sait très bien que le meilleur moyen
d'agir pour lutter contre la pauvreté
beaucoup d'études l'ont montré c'est de
soutenir les femmes les collectifs de
femmes parce que c'est elle qui ont en
charge l'alimentation dans beaucoup
beaucoup de pays y compris la culture et
l'agriculture et que donc là notre aide
publique elle est pas encore assez
féministe elle est pas encore assez
nourrie par une lecture de genre donc il
y a encore beaucoup de choses à faire
mais oui la France a fait des efforts en
la matière il faut qu'elle continue
dernière question elle joue parce qu'on
voit vous êtes encore très engagés et
c'est qu'on va vous vous les portez au
fond de vous-même est-ce que aujourd'hui
un retour en politique est totalement
exclu pour vous alors écoutez pour
l'instant et ça fait plus de 4 ans
maintenant que je suis la directrice
d'Oxfam et je dois vous dire que dans la
période qu'on vient de traverser être
dans une organisation internationale
savoir qu'on partage ses combats au
Niger aux États-Unis au Brésil je pense
très très fort à ma collègue Katia qui a
été sur la liste des personnalités
menacées par par les sbires de bolsonaro
ça donne une force très importante parce
que ça se dit que ce qu'on peut faire
changer en France on peut le faire
changer ailleurs dans le monde ensuite
quand j'ai arrêté la politique j'ai
arrêté avant de devenir cynique et gris
et j'ai jamais dit que c'était pour
toujours mais ça veut pas dire que ça
arrivera un jour voilà en tout cas ce
qui est sûr c'est que
les causes pour lesquelles nous
combattons cette question de justice
sociale et du climat elles ont été
rattrapées par la réalité c'est à dire
que les allers des écologistes elles
sont réelles donc ça va aller encore
plus la nécessité de mettre en oeuvre
ses solutions et de le faire quand vous
voyez la gauche aujourd'hui quand vous
voyez le la montée de l'extrême droite
dans de nombreux pays européens y
compris la France est-ce que vous dites
que vous aussi vous allez envier vous
avez envie de retourner dans ce combat
là c'est pas une lecture personnelle
mais est-ce que je pense que la solution
qu'il faut mettre en oeuvre face à cette
montée du populisme et surtout du d'une
sorte d'inquiétude parce que aux
États-Unis aux États-Unis pardon en
Italie il s'est passé la même chose
qu'en France
l'immense majorité n'a pas voté
c'est-à-dire qu'il y a une désaffection
très forte du politique et ce que nous
disons à Oxfam c'est que il y a pas de
fatalité la situation politique elle est
le résultat de choix ou de non choix si
on met en oeuvre ce manifeste fiscal
qu'on récupère ses 65 milliards d'euros
le débat sur les services de santé le
débat sur le financement de la
transition énergétique mais ça veut dire
que oui il faut taxer les supers profits
il faut aussi taxer les plus riches mais
ce débat là il a été posé y compris par
le chef de la BCE et que la situation
d'inégalité qui est la nôtre ou des
extrêmement riches deviennent encore
plus encore plus riches non seulement
c'est pas une fatalité mais si on y met
fin finalement ils seront toujours très
très largement aussi riches pour faire
tout ce qu'ils veulent mais on arrivera
à plus de solidarité dans notre société
donc est-ce que je crois la politique
est-ce que je crois en l'action
politique plus que jamais merci beaucoup
Cécile Duflot merci beaucoup d'être venu
à nous voir ce matin et pour cet
entretien qui était passionnant merci
d'avoir été notre invité on passe au
club des territoires
[Musique]